I'm hopeful vice with Bobby and kalila
hi check your email because the picture
hi so for the past year I've been single
due to my wife and I separating I've
been on the dating apps not too long
after the separation and although I've
had some success with these apps it's
not as much as I was of wanted with long
droughts with no replies I was thinking
it might have to do with some of the
things I put on my profile that maybe
early 30-somethings might not find
appealing so my question is is it okay
to lie on my profile to appeal to more
women I am 31 with a management job in
retail separated in atheists have has
children and smokes regularly cocaine
you can't put in there that takes out
40% really yeah you have to say that
you're a little younger that's what I
did or am I just
or or am I just ugly here's a picture
not ugly you're definitely not ugly
you're definitely not ugly
a different type of but you're kind of
you're yeah you're a different kind of
guard off different guys it yeah he
looks very formal though I wonder where
he's going to Jersey like you should
have more like you should go for the
more homeless look and then not give a
[ __ ] look like Bobby does it's not even
just that the fault is if that's his
profile pic yeah no that's not good here
let me can I just say the girls
perspective like my first thing is never
put a mirror selfie yeah if you want to
attract the good ones this right here is
a big [ __ ] no no no gym shots and
definitely no mirror selfies it is it it
even though you could be the nicest guy
ever just on principle alone I would
swipe left I don't know why it's just
something that doesn't like sit well
with me I'm like that's so like it gives
an air of like at least kind of like
full of themselves hold a dog hold a dog
oh my god that's such a big thing also
dog also in your other profile pics you
have to be doing things that seem
exciting not just bathroom selfies
that's a huge one for me like for
instance what did you put on yours I
mean I I I told this is so gross but I
told Eric stone I went to Eric
Stonestreet his house yeah
and told him what he needs to be doing
I go be barbecuing with your most famous
friends I mean you know you you paint a
life that's not real that's it's all
fake right you're hooking them in you're
fishing right so what I do is I make it
seem like you know this is daily life
for me Bobby
the point being on a mountain yeah yes
you have a point because you're never
gonna be able to portray who you really
are your most authentic self your [ __ ]
we all are pieces of [ __ ] so the point
is to just get enough of their time to
where they can maybe present yourself
you're real authentic self and maybe
capture them in that way fake it till
you make it but definitely no mirror
selfies and I do think he I sir if
you're listening you are a handsome man
and I think that this photo right here
the photo with the puppy that I have
here smiling with that puppy would
probably be my profile photo that's good
you [ __ ] poser all right this right
here would be just a traffic galore let
me see oh yeah yeah yeah with the puppy
my smiley riot would you put on with you
on the stage doing stand-up no that's my
sixth photo Thanks yeah that's like the
last yeah no that's kind of like girls
cuz I like the first show Friday after
Sacramento was out in San Francisco I
kind of standing oh yeah I have somebody
take a photo that's good photo of
yourself on stage doing stand-up I would
have not swiped right your photos were
so well chosen and I thought like really
like even like humble because I had I
actually saw other comics on there yeah
and I didn't swipe on any other yeah I
will not say say one name there are a
couple but I I was like I don't like how
they presented themselves I don't know
terminator so armed yeah but dude let me
see something okay you gotta fake it
right because your real life isn't good
enough sorry dude no I did you know but
that's the truth you know it's like when
women do the same thing they do photos
from beads or just all the profile pics
are from the shoulder up
wait hang on when you saw me in real
life it's your leg your legs I know but
did my photographs like match my what I
look like in person no you don't way
bigger forehead in real life yeah that's
what I noticed I don't have a big
forehead I know but I know but still it
was still it was hot or something it was
shiny that's what I liked about it I'm
[ __ ] shiny forhead she has did you
think I was prettier the same or not as
pretty I liked everything about I liked
your accent they would eat a little bit
of an accent and I this is what I the
thing that I remember the most was you
most women when they meet me or have
dinner they scoot away from me that's
never sad but they want they just kind
of through the day they just kind of are
further further away you know like five
feet five or ten feet right
but with kalila I noticed she was closer
right and even when we went in I
remember distinctly that clothing store
we went to that vintage clothing store
right and I remember watching you watch
me that was nice yeah you're washing his
ass
well no he was just cut she was kind of
looking up while she's shopping
and I you know I looked up until giggle
no strategy on my part the whole clothes
thing yeah it's me saying like I'm not
afraid of you like you don't know what
about the other one where I knew the guy
and then I went in the back and I jumped
on top of all those clothes
oh that move was pretty good moved in
damn close no the guy just knew me I was
like oh this is my chance
that's dude that's a that's a good one
yeah no but that's the that's the only
reason why we need to tell the story now
we went to a vintage store cuz I lived
right by fourth Street which is like a
bunch of vintage shops and we was like
let's go to this shop and then the owner
of the shop was like hey I have like
this big mountain of clothes back there
do you want to jump on it and I can take
a picture and so he did and that was his
moment and that was cute I posted on
Instagram yeah and then my question was
I prettier uglier or the same as the
film you're prettier in real life oh
thank God I wasn't false advertising but
your legs were the ones they're not
quite the same now though nice to
Louisville I love your legs yeah you're
smaller than the rest of your body but
they're very cute and your hair
distribution is cancerous it's like it's
Mad Max I think that your thighs are
cancerous
it's Mad Max yeah like why don't you
have five because I had cancer just
right here I did chemotherapy just right
here spot spot Kiba it's not spot chemo
yeah yeah I don't even know why like God
put some here but I think he you know
when God made me or designed me he would
just was in a hurry first now I'm gonna
make a million of those yeah and he put
too much personality like he [ __ ] me
up
[Music]